For most of the
problems we will be
facing in the next few
weeks, we will only
need to work in two dimensions.
We use a 2D coordinate system
so we can formally put vectors
on a grid and more easily
do these vector operations.
Once we have our axes, the next
thing we need are unit vectors.
Unit vectors have
a magnitude of 1
and are in a defined direction.
For a normal x, y
coordinate system,
we have i hat in the positive
x direction and j hat
in the positive y direction.
In Cartesian coordinates,
the unit vectors
are the same no matter what
point in space we're at.
We can also define a unit
vector in the direction
of an arbitrary vector.
The key here is to make sure
it has a magnitude of 1.